marée noire tout est à refaire les
nappes de pétrole sont revenus sur les
côtes du pc la contestation de la ligne
marché s'amplifie les commentaires de
alain duhamel emploi augmentation du
chômage de presque 3% pour la fin mark
jacques blanc succède à jean pierre
soisson un médecin de la lozère dirige
le parti républicain
bah là mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
tout est à refaire ou presque les
militaires et les volontaires qui depuis
quelques jours croyait avoir vaincu la
marée noire dans la région de portsall
sont désespérés aujourd'hui les plages
et les criques qu'ils avaient nettoyé
avec beaucoup de difficultés sont à
nouveau recouvertes de pétrole en
bretagne depuis deux jours le vent a
tourné
le pétrole de l'amoco cadiz a maintenant
atteint les îles de molène et d'ouessant
la rade de brest et veut lancer de la
pointe saint-mathieu à l'embouchure de
la bête bresse jusqu'à post border 40 km
de côtes jusqu'à présent épargnés sont
maintenant pollué le pô sport d'air
l'aber benoît 35 km de côtes nettoyer
sont de nouveau recouverts de mazout en
face ouest en est surtout molène touché
également ses il faisait parti des
régions épargnées jusqu'à présent autour
de l'épave démanteler de la un pic
bravery des nappes ballotté par les
flots des criques fortement englué une
plage à paul et des blancs sablons
maculé sur toute sa longueur 6 km de la
côte jusqu'aux îles d'ouessant et de
molène des irisations sont visibles
problème on ne peut pas traiter ces
irisation actuellement des troupes sont
transférés du nord vers l'ouest 500
hommes
trois autres compagnies devraient
arriver prochainement les pompes
d'assainissement et les pompes à lisier
ont été rappelés le travail sera
difficile car la météo est mauvaise en
mer quinze bâtiments de la marine
nationale traite les quelques nappes qui
menacent encore en rade de brest
sept barrages ont été posées rapidement
ce matin
ces images la plage de portal ont été
prises hier la plage étaient encore à
peu près propre à 18 heures lors du
tournage nous interrogions alors
secrétaire du comité des pêches de
bretagne sur ses craintes quant à
l'extension des nappes de pétrole il
nous parlait des dangers pour les baies
de saint brieuc et de brest et des
conséquences catastrophiques que
pourrait avoir la marée noire sur ces
régions
on peut craindre dans les semaines qui
viennent la baie de saint brieuc alors
qu'il ya un gisement une trier coquille
et pendant de très grande importance
soit touchée ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement espérons que ça ne sera pas
le cas mais si la paix saint brieuc été
touché ce serait une véritable
catastrophe pour les marins pêcheurs
secteur il y a également entendu parmi
nos inquiétudes la rade de brest qui est
une zone de pêche importantes en matière
de coquilles saint jacques près répétons
on y fait également de l'huître
actuellement et n'est pas touché mais
compte tenu du déplacement des nappes se
serait également très grasse il demain
dans quelques jours la rade de brest
serait touchée ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement
brest est sauvé mais sur 75 km de côtes
tout est à refaire militaire et
volontaires devront reprendre le chemin
des plages et des criques avec pelles
seaux râteau raclée pompaire à nouveau
des rochers du sable qui n'auront été
propre que quelques heures
si le drame se poursuit la solidarité
des français continue elle aussi de
jouer c'est ainsi que l'un des
restaurateurs les plus connus de france
andré daguin qui dirige à l'hôtel à auch
dans le gers a lancé aujourd'hui un
appel à tous ses confrères cuisiniers
restaurateurs est faux at il déclaré
faire le maximum pour aider les pêcheurs
bretons il demande donc aux cuisines et
de toute la france d'inscrire sur leur
menu un maximum de produits venant de
bretagne notamment des huîtres et des
crustacés
le président du sporting club de bastia
rêve du parc des princes jules filippi
le directeur sportif préfèrerait que son
équipe joue à marseille les joueurs eux
souhaitent disputer le match aller de la
finale de la coupe de l'uefa sur leur
stade fétiche de furiani l'adversaire
est maintenant connue ce sera le psv
eindhoven à l'adversaire difficile et
les joueurs de bastia pense qu'ils
auront besoin de tous leurs supporters
pour l'emporter
des supporters bruyants vous avez pu le
constater en suivant le match hier soir
sur antenne
les supporters expansif et exubérant on
n'a pas beaucoup dormi cette nuit encore
s'il fallait fêter ça c'est grâce à pape
pie l'auteur du fameux but si les corses
ont pu fêter ça c'est aussi grâce à papy
si le sporting étoiles club de bastia
est à la une ce soir ils sont tous
d'autant plus fier que papy citoyens de
porto vecchio est l'un des 3 corse de
l'équipe et que l'on verra le drapeau et
le maillot à tête de maure pour la
première fois dans une finale de coupe
d'europe on n'a pas beaucoup dormi dans
l'île la nuit dernière c'est vrai et
jusqu'au petit jour les supporters
corses ont mis bastia en ébullition
seule ombre au tableau pour tous les
inconditionnels des bleus il n'est pas
sûr du tout que l'on jouera l'une des
deux rencontres de la finale dans le
sanctuaire de furiani claude président
nathalie vie vient de nous préciser
juste avant le journal réserve sa
réponse jusqu'à dimanche contre 1 là bas
les vives réactions des corses au cas où
la décision serait prise de jouer sur le
continent ce serait peut-être une bonne
opération financière mais les supporters
corses n'ont cure
une telle décision risquerait fort de
mécontenter tout ceux qui n'ont jamais
cessé d'apporter leur soutien à l'équipe
elle risquerait aussi de provoquer une
autre folle nuit à bastia mais qui
n'aurait pas bien évidemment la même
signification attendant dimanche
la suite des élections légistatives au
sein du parti communiste l'humanité et
dément les informations publiées ces
derniers jours selon lesquelles monsieur
georges marcheurs étaient est mis en
minorité au secrétariat du pcs mais
cette mise au point et empêche pas la
discussion de se poursuivre ainsi
maurice goldring membre du comité de
rédaction de l'hebdomadaire du pc france
nouvelle estime que la politique du
parti vaut mieux que l'image cahotant
qui en a été donnée notre politique
écrit-il a besoin de démocratie interne
pour être mises en oeuvre
elle ne peut que se dessécher si elle
s'en privent critique aussi de la
politique menée par les responsables du
parti dans le mensuel la nouvelle
critique la difficulté traverse tout le
parti écrit francis cohen
elle vient de ce que la pratique
démocratique est encore loin d'avoir
gagné chez nous enfin le monde poursuit
aujourd'hui la publication d'un longue
article signé par monsieur jean l
pour le directeur adjoint du centre
d'études et de recherches marxiste le
parti communiste doit se transformer
profondément
on ne peut pas s'adresser aux ouvriers
comme il y à 50 ans écrit jean hélène
stein qui pense que le mot d'ordre faire
payer les riches a été souvent utilisés
disons sans nuance et jean epstein
explique la défaite de mars nous n'avons
pas convaincu écrit-il pis encore nous
avons décourager les bonnes volontés et
fait peur bien au delà de l'électorat
socialiste jusqu'aux tours 2 alors elle
a lu hamel en dépit des démentis de
l'humanité la discussion s'amplifie on
le voit au sein du parti communiste on
peut toutefois se demander si la masse
des militants
si les ouvriers de chez renault par
exemple sont concernés par ces
discussions que représentent les
contestataires je joue bon alors il est
clair que ceux qui s'expriment le plus
c'est normal parce que c'est leur
formation que c'est eux qui ont le
démentaient de notoriété davantage
l'habitude de le faire ce sont des
intellectuels c'est d'ailleurs le cas
chaque fois qu'une crise à l'intérieur
du parti communiste il est clair aussi
que par exemple jean allane stein quand
ils utilisent des expressions à propos
de l'union soviétique comme d'un anti
modèle ou quand il dit qu à certains
moments il ya peut-être eu de lentilles
socialisme primaire au parti communiste
il est clair qu'il est très en avance
sur la moyenne des militants cela dit à
chaque fois qu'une crise ce sont les
intellectuels qui s'exprime et en gros
l'immense majorité de ceux qui est a pas
en ce moment en publie des articles dans
au moins maintenant une dizaine de
journaux différents
cet immense majorité d'intellectuels qui
s'exprime de cette façon se dit fidèle à
la ligne du 22e congrès c'est-à-dire
demande qu'en réalité la ligne du
dernier congrès du parti communiste soit
amplifiée comptage et qu'on aille à
l'intérieur du parti commise vers
davantage de démocratie donc si vous
voulez de ce point de vue ils sont
typiques ils sont en avance mais ils
sont typiques alors est ce qu'il ya fait
le monsieur georges marchais est en
vacances tranquillement algéro il hume
l'humanité dément qu'il y ait la moindre
divergence de vues au sein du pc par
crise ou pas crise
bon il ya plusieurs choses la première
c'est que s'ils voulaient y ait un petit
peu des règlements de compte
en ce qui concerne les erreurs tactiques
qui ont pu être faites 10 en simplifiant
depuis septembre dernier
de ce point de vue il ya un certain
nombre de militants sûrement qu'ils ont
trouvé que le pc lui même avec qu'ils
étaient d'accord pour l'essentiel mais
enfin en rajouter dans les critiques à
l'égard du parti socialiste jusqu'aux
élections
il ya ceux qui n'ont pas compris
l'accord au lendemain du premier tour
et puis à ce et qui ont été je pense
plus nombreux qui ont été choqués du
fait que la direction du pc au lendemain
action a dit que le pc en ce qui le
concerne et ne porter aucune
responsabilité dans la défaite de la
stratégie électorale voilà c'est ça
alors la deuxième chose qui est à mon
avis la plus importante c'est que il ya
une critique sur l'insuffisance de
démocratie à l'intérieur du pc si vous
voulez ceux qui s'expriment publiquement
trouve d'abord que c'est trop l'appareil
le sommet qui décide d'un certain nombre
de choses pour ne prendre que trois
exemples en ce qui concerne les
élections au parlement européen au
suffrage universel direct dans ce qui
concerne la force de frappe ou en ce qui
concerne la dictature du prolétariat son
abandon se sont un peu 3 3 nouvelles
qu'ils ont appris comme ça par la
télévision ou par la radio et ils sont
aujourd'hui relativement hostile par
exemple aux fictions d'unanimité au
sommet puis ils savent que dans le parti
comme et italiens ou dans le parti
communiste espagnol
on peut exprimer des divergences sans
être considéré comme trahissant les
règles de vie d'un parti communiste et
puis enfin il ya une troisième chose
c'est que maintenant il va falloir que
le parti communiste fasse un petit peu
ses propres comptes c'est à dire que les
élections étaient perdus c'est à dire
que le parti communiste a perdu presque
un point alors que vous savez que vous
vous rappelez qu'il espérait faire entre
21 et 25 % il avait il assez loin voilà
c'est ça il a fait moins de 21 et peut
il est aujourd'hui naturellement
davantage isolé qu'il ne l'était avant
en particulier par rapport à la gauche
non communiste donc d'un petit peu
falloir qu'ils se demandent maintenant
pourquoi faire merci côté socialiste
maintenant monsieur françois mitterrand
dans un article publié dans l'unité le
parti socialiste doit mettre en chantier
sans plus tarder le projet autour duquel
s'organiseront pour les années
prochaines notre pensée et notre action
l'objectif écrit françois mitterrand
sera de parfaire l'identité et la
personnalité socialiste condition
première est nécessaire de la victoire
de la gauche
côté majorité premiers résultats des
élections et aussi de la formation du
nouveau gouvernement de monsieur raymond
barre le parti républicain a changé ce
matin de secrétaire général monsieur
jean pierre soisson est devenu dans le
gouvernement barre ministre de la
jeunesse des sports et des loisirs
mais ce soit sont devenus ministres il a
fallu lui trouver un remplaçant à la
tête du parti républicain
monsieur jacques blanc assurera
l'intérim jusqu'au congrès de fréjus en
mai prochain
c'est ce congrès qui ratifiera sa
nomination à titre définitif
la transmission des pouvoirs on constate
s est faite ce matin dans la bonne
humeur
à l'issue de la réunion du bureau
politique du parti républicain
il va vite jacques blanc car il a
horreur de faire attendre
même sa carrière né à rodez médecins à
27 ans il exerce à la canourgue petite
commune de lozère dont il devient député
maire à 34 dynamique affable il grimpe
vite les échelons de son parti à
l'époque les airs et il y a un an il
devient secrétaire d'état à
l'agriculture 39 ans quatre enfants de
18 mois à 13 ans jacques blanc cherche
un appartement dans la capitale pour
circuler il s'achètera un cyclomoteur il
n'aime pas la vie parisienne
je voudrais garder c'est de me laisser
enfermer justement dans des cercles
parisiens
je crois que c'est dans la france
profonde rural vrai où l'on peut mieux
sentir les vrais problèmes ce qui
intéresse l'ensemble des français puis
vous savez que ce département de la
lozère est un département où se
rencontrent justement à la fois les
ruraux vers leur profond et aussi des
citadelles nombreux qui viennent et
retrouver un peu leur équilibre
donc je crois que de cette rencontre eh
bien je pourrai tirer les meilleurs
enseignements pour ne pas m'enfermer
donc dans la vie parisienne mais au
contraire pour rester au contact direct
est vrai avec l'ensemble des français
les ruraux mais aussi des citadelles en
lozère on l'appelle coco les français le
connaissent mieux sous le nom de
monsieur vacances la demande du chef de
l'état y publient l'été dernier un
rapport intitulé choisir ses loisirs
son but démocratiser les vacances
développer le tourisme vert jean jacques
revaux par exemple c'est l'une des
aspirations des français en tant que
leader du prr il veut d'y répondre comme
au sol et mon ambition est de gagner un
nouveau pari et qui est celui de créer
par le parti républicain un grand
mouvement d' enthousiasme
derrière le projet qu'a développé le
président de la république et de montrer
à l'ensemble des français comme na des
réponses à leurs vraies aspirations son
livre de chevet démocratie française
jacques blanc comptent rester longtemps
rue de la bienfaisance et se rendre
souvent sur le terrain il n'a pas
d'états d'âme ses relations avec les
autres formations de la majorité seront
dit-il sans agressivité et sans complexe
le patron des patrons monsieur françois
ceyrac sera reçu le jeudi 20 avril par
monsieur raymond barre demain c'est le
secrétaire général de la cfdt monsieur
edmond maire qui sera reçue à l'hôtel
matignon thème central de ces entretiens
le redressement des bas salaires dont la
progression du pouvoir d'achat doit être
plus rapide que pour les autres
dans une interview à notre confrère la
croix monsieur edmond maire parle
d'ailleurs de l'avenir même avec une
politique économique peut changer un
certain nombre de possibilités existent
affirme le leader de la cfdt
c'est à nous de faire en sorte que ces
possibilités soit explorer à fond
conclusion d'edmond maire il ne faut
jamais voir le changement comme un tout
ou à rien le chiffre du chômage à la fin
du mois de mars en données corrigées des
variations saisonnières on comptait à
cette date 1 millions 70 mille chômeurs
soit une hausse de 2 7% par rapport au
mois de février en données brutes le
nombre des demandeurs d'emploi diminué
en revanche de 2 4 % et s'établit à 1
millions 73 mille chômeurs contre un
million cent mille à la fin février
toujours en social on peut prévoir
quelques difficultés samedi et dimanche
dans les ports français la cgt appelle
les dockers à cesser le travail samedi
en totalité et en partie dimanche de
conflit porte sur l'application de la
convention collective aussi sur un
certain nombre d' avantages salariaux
sachez encore que monsieur andré rossi
député de l'aisne ancien ministre du
commerce extérieur a été désigné
aujourd'hui comme chef de la délégation
française au conseil économique et
social des nations unies et que le
sénateur henri caillavet à proposer une
loi aujourd'hui une loi qui prévoit
qu'un malade incurable devrait pouvoir
demander sa mort tous majeurs sain
d'esprit à la faculté de déclarer sa
volonté qu'aucun moyen médical ou
chirurgical autres que ceux destinés à
calmer la souffrance ne soit utilisé
pour prolonger artificiellement sa vie
s'il est atteint d'une affection
accidentelle ou incurable voilà le texte
de la proposition de loi de monsieur k
ya trois ans jour pour jour après le
début de la guerre civile au liban les
combats qui ont repris il ya cinq jours
à beyrouth se sont poursuivies toute la
journée les principaux affrontements se
déroulent entre miliciens conservateur
et la force arabe de dissuasion composé
en majorité de soldats syriens un accord
de cessez-le-feu a été conclu il y à
quelques minutes la situation explosive
que connaît le liban n'est
en réalité personne aujourd'hui les
miliciens les palestiniens en armes ou
bien les militaires sont maintenant plus
nombreux presque que les civils dans ce
pays au milieu de tout cela il y a les
casques bleus qui essaient de faire
tampon entre israël et le sud du liban
des casques bleus qui doivent se garder
de tout côté ils ne savent pas si les
obus qui tombent autour d'eux sont tirés
par des israéliens des palestiniens des
syriens des soudanais des chrétiens ou
bien les progressistes et j'en oublie
encore
la poudrière du liban c'est aujourd'hui
une dizaine d'armées dans un pays de 3
millions d'habitants à peine plus grand
que la corse
l'armée syrienne d'abord ils sont
quarante mille sous couvert de la force
arabe de dissuasion chargé d'empêcher la
reprise de la guerre civile
c'est contre cette armée syrienne que
les chrétiens viennent de reprendre les
armes
ils veulent que les soldats de damas
évacuent le liban avec leurs amis
palestiniens
les milices chrétiennes ses quarante
mille hommes superbement armée qui
entendent restaurer la souveraineté
nationale sur le territoire libanais en
chassant les fedayin et toutes les
armées étrangères
les palestiniens ils sont quatre cent
mille réfugiés armés pour la plupart
avec une troupe de choc de 50000 fedayin
renforcer en cas de besoin par des
volontaires de l'armée irakienne à leurs
côtés selon l'humeur du moment
les milices musulmanes et la gauche
libanaise vingt mille combattants
dispersés dans une vingtaine
d'organisations qui aide les fedayin à
harceler l'armée israélienne les
israéliens ont encore dix mille hommes
stationnés au sud liban depuis leur
intervention du 15 mars le retrait
israélien a commencé officiellement mais
les soldats de tel aviv mettront
plusieurs mois avant d'évacuer toutes
leurs positions
le sud-liban voit à présent le
contingent français
un millier d'hommes sous le casque des
nations unies finir de s'installer pour
superviser le désengagement des forces
avec les soldats iraniens suédois et
népal est envoyé par l'onu les casques
bleus seront bientôt 4000 à contrôler le
liban sud
les seuls absents sont finalement les
soldats libanais l'armée régulière
éclaté depuis la dernière guerre civile
ne parvient pas à refaire son unité et
depuis la reprise des combats n'ose plus
sortir de ces casernes de l'autre côté
de la frontière libanaise en israël
cette situation au liban un suivi avec
beaucoup d'attention
des roquettes sont d'ailleurs tombés ce
matin sur le territoire israélien
il n'y a pas eu de victimes mais cela
n'encouragera pas le gouvernement de
tel-aviv à faire accélérer le retrait de
ses troupes du sud liban en israël
d'ailleurs on se montre aussi irrité par
une déclaration faite hier par le
président carter le chef de l'état
américain qui recevait le président
roumain monsieur ceausescu a fait disons
un lapsus à propos du proche orient
jimmy carter a félicité en ces termes le
premier roumain d'avoir servi
d'intermédiaire entre israéliens et
égyptiens
écoutez le président carter
capital israël jérusalem jusque là pour
les israéliens pas de problème mais
voilà peu après cette déclaration le
président carter est revenue de lui même
sur ses propos en affirmant que la
capitale d'israël
c'était et c'est toujours tel aviv une
rectification qui est irrité que ce
matin les milieux politiques israël
en israël on souligne en effet que ce
pays n'a qu'une seule capitale et que
cette capitale s'est effectivement
jérusalem est
les israéliens ce soir ont aussi un
autre problème dans le monde entier la
presse proteste contre l'arrestation
d'une journaliste palestinienne vraiment
data où il a été arrêté il ya trois
semaines a été appréhendé par la police
à la suite d'une manifestation organisée
en cisjordanie pour protester contre
l'entrée des troupes israéliennes dans
le sud du liban
95 % de la cisjordanie sans plomb sp
chaque maison chaque citoyen nous nous
reconnaissons en lui et pour nous c'est
c'est une nouveauté chaque personne qui
est dans la saison nice et l'ol t on
peut pas diviser le peuple palestinien
en deux c'est pas loin des kits de bord
holt et ses devoirs et de danse ans
c'est la même famille palestinien qui
est divisé les familles qui sont dans le
camp de réfugiés les familles qui vivent
ici ce qui est une évolution est ce qui
est une acceptation quand même de la
réalité israélienne de reconnaître un
état qui a été fondée sur les robinets
du peuple palestinien mais ils sont
forcés parce que c'est un fait accompli
est là pour la politique c'est l'art du
possible
c'est gérard ce bac qui avait interrogé
il y a quelques mois
raimon date d'avril en cisjordanie 80
avec des catholiques et aussi des
représentants des églises anglicanes
orthodoxes et protestantes forme depuis
trois jours à chantilly une véritable
europe de l'oecuménisme sommet
historique qui réunit les représentants
de toutes les églises d'europe
à l'origine de cette session une double
paternité le conseil des conférences
épiscopales d'europe que préside
monseigneur etchegaray et la conférence
des églises européennes dirigée par le
pasteur andré appellent l'europe dans
laquelle nous trouvant est une europe
divisée au point de vue religieux c'est
une europe où hélas on peut dire que la
plupart des déchirures confessionnelle
des divisions chrétiens sont nés en
europe
qu'ils s'agissent de l'anglicanisme
qu'ils s'agissent de l'orthodoxie qu'ils
s'agissent des pros du protestantisme
c'est en europe sont nés ses divisions
alors penser que des sommes chrétiens
divisés en fait mais qui ont la même
origine évangélique puissent se
retrouver pour refaire le d'issue de
l'unité de l'église c'est capital et
quel parallèle faites vous entre
l'europe communiqué l'europe politique
parallèle je crois pas qu'il y en ait ce
que je dirai simplement ce que pour nous
chrétiens
il n'y a pas de barrières politiques une
église n'est pas dépendante des
vicissitudes de la politique et ce qui
nous permet d'emblée de réunir des
chrétiens de l'atlantique à l'oural et
nous faisons fi de toutes les barrières
idéologiques et nous nous retrouvons
comme chrétiens tous comme disciple du
christ alors si c'est très important au
point de vue religieux parce que
voyez-vous l'europe il faut pas la
considérer comme repliée sur elle-même
nous pensons au monde entier et quand on
se dit que il y à des travailleurs
musulmans qui a des étudiants asiatiques
qui en europe peut-être pour la seule
chance de rencontrer des chrétiens c'est
ici chez nous alors il s'agirait de bien
prendre cette chance de manière ce que
le régime puisse être connue par tous la
réalisatrice et productrice de
télévision aimé mortimer est morte ce
matin à paris des suites d'une longue
maladie
d'abord cantatrice et mortimer avait
réalisé et animé et et la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale de nombreuses
émissions à la radio et à la télévision
coupé du reste du monde voilà ce qui
arrive depuis quatre jours aux quelques
4000 touristes du petit village de
valloire en savoie la route qui mène à
la station s'est effondrée sur une
trentaine de mètres
les mesures de sauvegarde ont été prises
immédiatement mais les naufragés de la
neige ont plutôt garder dix ont bon
moral et pour les 800 écoliers c'est une
bonne nouvelle que ces congés
supplémentaires
valoir isolé depuis cinq jours c'est
vrai la route est coupée
mais ce n'est pas pour autant une île
les voitures ne passent plus mes hommes
et vivre monte jusqu'à la station depuis
cinq jours
50 tonnes de nourriture ont été coltiner
d'un bord à l'autre de la brèche et
avaloirs on n'a jamais manqué de rien ce
qui importe c'est la voiture bloquée et
aussi les frais que cela entraîne elle
avait pris de demander la vence de quoi
du billet du train les problèmes de
voiture mais ma voiture doit rester ici
monsieur et j'habite le haras avec j'ai
trois enfants nous a donné des délais
pour la récupérer on n'a rien donné une
patte délai du tout aucune garantie il
paraît qu'à sera bien surveillé par la
police
après je ne sais pas monsieur je devrais
perdre trois jours pour venir la
chercher
et puis je ça me coûte 86 mille francs
pour répartir par le train
la situation est embarrassante c'est
vrai mais il ya quand même des
exceptions pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
voiture et pour ceux aussi que la
rentrée de lundi ne comble pas tout à
fait c'est mieux pour les gens qui pour
les gens qui sont en vacances ici et
puis qui est qui en août a commencé
d'argent que pour rester une semaine
deux semaines qu'ils peuvent pas
repartir mais pour nous c'est amusant
parce qu'on des cours à la mairie on a
fait dit on ce que l'on a pu et valoir
n'est pas isolé seules les voitures ne
peuvent pas descendre de valloire où il
monte mais en ce qui concerne les
personnes
il n'y a aucune difficulté à décembre à
la gare de saint michel ou un remontée
et en ce qui concerne les marchandises
il n'y a aucune difficulté car le
transbordement être assurée grâce à
l'aide de l'armée
autrement dit valoir n'est pas isolé et
seules les voitures ne peut pas
descendre les automobilistes vous
reproche de ne pas avancer le prix du
billet du train aussi à des gens qui
n'ont pas d'argent comme donc ils n'ont
pas prévu cette éventualité
oui alors là aussi je conteste il s'agit
certainement des bruits qui se propage
assez rapidement et qui sont un contrôle
et des mesures ont été prises
non pas pour payer aux gens le billet de
train de retour mais pour avancer les
frais correspondants c'est à dire les
gens qui ne peuvent pas rentrer avec
leur voiture au moyen d'un bon prix à
l'office du tourisme peuvent avoir leur
billet de train gratuitement et leurs
enfants seront ultérieurement par les
chemins de notre percepteur nous allons
maintenant essayer de porter les choses
sur un sera un plan peut-être plus
politique en ce sens que peut-être le
conseil général acceptera de
d'indemniser une partie justement des
frais occasionnés par le retour des gens
par chemin de fer leur retour à nouveau
à valoir pour revenir chercher leur
véhicule c'est ici juste dernières mois
que la route est parti en bas dans la
vallée
le seul passage qui reste c'est cette
petite pas sale qui fait un petit peu
plus d'un mètre de large et qui ne
permet que le passage des piétons il ya
derrière la forêt un petit chemin qui
permet de monter à la station mais cela
fait quelque chose comme sept ou huit
kilomètres à pied la station manque pour
le moment un peu d'essence on a gardé
une réserve là haut
mais dès demain l'essence va arriver
grâce à l'aide des pompiers l'essence ne
pourra pas passer bien entendu par
camion alors on va lancer un tuyau de
cette pile de pont qui est écoulé
pendant la nuit quand on va tirer un
point ici dans la semaine qui vient est
l'autre coquereau idée du tuyau mais pas
de l'autre côté et on pourrait ainsi
passer quelque chose comme cinq mille
litres d'essence alors cette route pose
un certain nombre d'inquiétudes parce
que cet endroit est parti dans la vallée
mais un peu plus haut dans certains
virages et bien la route commence à se
gondoler et on se demande s'il ne va pas
y avoir d'autres effondrements
vous l'avez constaté il y avait des
petits bruits dans ce reportage et puis
aussi une petite faute de couleurs ce
n'était pas votre poste de télévision
qui tombait en panne ça venait de chez
nous je vous prie de bien vouloir nous
en excuser
rapidement le tiercé se disputer
aujourd'hui à auteuil dans la 4e course
et pour l'emporter il fallait jouer le
vin le xiii de 16 vous voyez les
rapports pour 5 francs je vous les
laisse lire assez longtemps c'est un
beau tiercé voilà avant de refermer ce
journal les prévisions de la météo pour
demain le matin beaucoup de nuages
accompagnés de pluies sur pratiquement
l'ensemble du pays seuls seront épargnés
les régions méditerranéennes l'après
midi le temps deviendra plus variable
avec des averses fréquentes températures
en légère hausse vers 23h15 vous
retrouverez gérard holtz pour la
dernière édition de cette journée quant
à moi je vous souhaite de passer une
excellente fin de soirée à l'écouté bien
sûr d'antenne 2 à demain bonsoir